today the european union
and algeria have adopted the priorities of the
partnership within the framework of the new
european neighborhood policy this
decision reflects a qualitative leap in
our bilateral relationship
we have decided to deepen
our strategic cooperation even further than
our  dialogue on the common challenges that
we share and also our responses to
these challenges in terms of
regional security we discussed at length
our common work in the sahel in
mali but also in libya and africa the
fight against terrorism and other
areas of cooperation  such
as cooperation on
migration mobility but also cooperation
on the energy of jelly underlined
place wants to be a partner of Algeria in
the reform the diversification of its
economy in order to enable it to
attract investments and  to open up
prospects corresponding to a potential
which in our opinion has not yet been
fully exploited.  It is up to us to see
how we can revitalize its
reforms, which is why we
will have to sign today the
cooperation program amounting to 40
million euros, which will further strengthen our
cooperation, which I am sure will
contribute to  our efforts to
diversify the economy
we intend to get the best out
of this association agreement and to
project ourselves together resolutely
towards a future that will be
qualitatively better for both
parties the in-depth friendly frank dialogue
that we have had
today  today is truly
up to the expectations of both sides
this spirit of working together this
spirit of combining efforts will
result in contacts and
[Applause]